did you see well i can't say did you see
have you had a chance to avoid seeing
the fight between chris rock and will
smith well i saw everything that
happened i mean how could you when you
saw the word will trending you're like
what's up i know i'm like i know about
my engagement what's going exactly
exactly
here's a question here's a question i
got for you and then you know i want to
get your thoughts and then i'll get mine
as well so it was it
your position for first time when you
saw it has it been the same from the
first moment to now or has it gone
i can't believe what he did well it kind
of does make sense because of jada oh
but you know what i can't believe what
where are you at with what happened with
wilson and jada my opinion has always
kind of been the same on all these kind
of things when i watch celebrities do
stupid stuff at the oscars or whatever
it is and for me i personally just don't
care much i think that people blow a lot
of these things out of proportion and to
me it's just
not something that i'm ever super
interested in i leave celebrities and to
other people but what it seems like in
terms of the whole situation i don't
think will smith was justified in doing
it but i can understand that as a
husband you get angry when someone says
something but you don't lash out in that
type of way i mean it just seems
childish and immature to go up there and
slap someone especially like open hand
slap like not even a punch you said
that's a [ __ ] right there's what that's
called you know it's it's not like a
manly punch it's a slap yeah which makes
it even worse yeah it makes it even i
mean the uh
diaz brothers they're famous for
fighting guys and you have scenes saying
i [ __ ] slap you so they like that idea
oh have you ever seen this or no yeah
there's videos of all they want to do is
slap you in your face in the fight okay
not a punch too slappy because they get
a kick out of it but what are your
thoughts when you saw this but by the
way just just before you even say this
jim carrey did you see what jim carrey
said what jim have to say so jim carrey
says a day ago the video's got like 10
million views jim carrey says i can't
believe the oscars did a standing
ovation for will smith if it was me and
you did that i would sue you the next
day for 200 million dollars did you hear
that or no he said i'm gonna see you for
200 million dollars on top of that he
says because that video is going to last
a lifetime this is permanent you're
going to get 200 million lawsuit for me
the next day that's what jim carrey said
who's a comedian going after will smith
what's your position let me tell you
something uh you would think story
somebody slaps the [ __ ] out of somebody
else whoever it is
you would assume like the nick diaz nate
diaz whoever did the slapping won and
whoever got their face [ __ ] slapped
would have lost let me tell you who the
big winner in this the whole situation
is chris rock
let me tell you guys i used to stand up
comedy for many years okay
before dave chappelle there was chris
rock people like i don't know if you're
25 i don't know if you really know
how big chris rock was in the 90s early
2000s everyone knows about dave
chappelle these days now it's kind of
moved from chappelle to like kevin hart
and there's other people out there chris
rock was the man and he's gotten a
little softer a little older a little
more hollywood more acting
when he did like
um his uh what was it blacker
dude you're talking about gangster ass
comedy chris rock
so
this was the best possible thing for his
career you can see the ticket sales have
gone from like 45 dollars show this up
minimum for a ticket to like 400 bucks
chris rock is trending for all the right
reasons and the guy took it like a g
like just
i i thought this was fake i thought this
was planned i thought this was stupid so
if you're watching this if you're
listening to this podcast how many of
you thought this was fake at first when
you saw it when your friend texts it to
you your reaction i think sam takes it
to me i'm like this got to be fake and
he's like no it's not fake so mario and
i played the video on you know how on
youtube you can go to point two five
speed of course you played on 0.25 speed
yeah and i'm like no i think i think we
should bring our friend paul in here
reenact the [ __ ] lab let will do it
yeah i'll do it yeah bring him in bring
him in here
okay so chris is the big winner here
notoriety yeah uh
financial yeah right um headlines we
just handled it like a man yeah there's
a guy he's like that's the greatest
moment in oscar's history yeah okay but
now let's talk about will smith
will smith has been getting emasculated
for the past year or two by his [ __ ]
wife
that he's been married to for 25 years
this whole entanglement red table talk
that they're doing
insanity will smith
was the coolest baddest dude on the
planet for two decades from well from
freshmen
you're right i don't know if there's an
actor that was loved and loved is the
word more than him yeah yeah from from
fresh prince yeah to men in black
to independence day to ali
you know
to
bad boys i mean the list goes on and on
and on don't forget now you got you got
to play hancock i mean all of that i
mean the list goes on and on i'm sure
there's going to be someone that's like
adam forgot about this movie and i hate
him okay i got it hitch pitch right damn
legend like he needs
thank you yeah
okay we got it we got it chris gardner
pursued up he needs to go back and watch
the movie that he frickin started called
hitch
because he's lost his mojo
that like this the whole [ __ ] slap with
chris rock
this has been brewing for years you
think he actually cares about this joke
he laughed at first he left she ended up
laughing at first
i feel like this was just boiling up
boiling up his i mean do you know about
this whole red table talk entanglement
august
augustus whatever
his wife is
literally having an affair cheating on
him with
the son's friend
yeah and now you're work like
like it was august athena thank you john
and now this is him fix your audience
seriously but he's dad bod synth vibes
it just i feel so bad for him think
about even before this years and years
ago the transition that willow has been
going through that his son has been
going through like this this family is
strange will was the only normal guy is
there a more
hollywood family
out there the father hollywood star jada
i know you have strong feelings on jada
the kids uh
jaden and willow two of my favorite
songs in the last five years have been
from the smith kids yeah the song wait a
minute
exactly that song icon from jaden like
they put out they they're great they're
very talented no doubt i mean you live
in l.a you know about like they're
talented as hell
but whatever is going on with this whole
entanglement has just
clearly been burying it down low and it
exploded at the oscars and then he won
the oscar i have a different opinion go
ahead so first of all like okay who won
you're right chris rock won and i think
jada won i think feminist movement won i
think women power one i think those who
give that message i think they want you
have to give them credit they won like
women are you know stronger than men and
look at how jada is very proud she's a
face of feminism if you think about it
because she's got him locked down right
um
you know who i am you know how i feel
about jada three years ago i don't know
what was two and a half years ago hector
del toro and jennifer teamed up together
right after the event i had at the
trump tower they had an event they had
hooked up and they sent me
the uh jada pinkett autographed picture
and it was in my office do you remember
this or no japanese autograph is sitting
on my desk right to the left and they
come look oh my god pat you got put this
picture away i'm like put this picture
away jennifer what's up to this with
hector what do we put this picture away
so sitting on my desk because i grew up
with jason's lyric okay and lyric is
jada pinkett in the movie with one of
the best soundtracks that i can go and
tell you the songs in the soundtrack but
i'm not going to talk
no no no
you're thinking about uh you're thinking
about with uh janet jackson that's quite
a joke
but now jason's lyric they used to date
is what i'm saying of course yeah so
tupac so so i'm a i'm a jada guy i grew
up being a jada guy i always loved jada
right so and i've always loved will so
the fact these guys that was kind of a
cool story now one of my friends 20-plus
years ago
um she would come to me and she would
say you know i know the will smith and i
know jada's story and i know them very
well i said really yeah
and she would say stories and i'm in la
20 some years she would say well let me
tell you know you know they have an open
relationship and they have this and they
have that i'm like it's none of my
business no they but they do like
everybody says stuff and the moment you
become a celebrity people say a lot of
different things and you can't believe
half the stuff no but i know it
personally how do you know a person i'm
just i can't tell you but i know and she
kept being very adamant like you know
somebody's very adamant and they don't
have a trend of being like that but this
one time they're extremely out of me
like okay and this is a friend of yours
this is a friend you know 20 years ago
and i'm listening to her like okay it
says but you also realize they're like
open with everything with their marriage
it's just a very private thing this is a
time that there's no social media
there's no facebook there's no twitter
there's no instagram so it's easier to
have that kind of a relationship in
hollywood and they're not the only ones
that's having a relationship so
so imagine this thing's going on all
these years they have an open
relationship all of a sudden all the
open relationships you've had let's just
say hypothetically none of them have
come out
it's all been private but this one guy
brings it out
august you know
and the next thing you know oh my gosh
you know will is as simple as this well
as that i believe will is sitting there
saying i wish you guys know how many
people i've been the last 25 years that
none of you guys know about that i've
been behind jada and jada took her
career in the backseat for 12 years for
me to go on my career and she was
popping at one point and she sacrificed
it for the kids you guys don't know how
much i've played around for the last 25
years but i kind of can't tell you guys
on tv because i will look like an idiot
if i do and i'm going to make jada look
bad so i don't think we know the whole
story and i think will is sitting there
saying
you idiots that are saying all this
stuff you're saying about me you don't
notice it's starting to really piss me
off and he reacted that reaction was
very deep that's my opinion i may be
wrong i may not be right with this
i think you're very right but you know
what i'm saying right i think deep down
inside will is
a man's man but i think willis also got
that conservative side because his dad
left you know that one scene in uh uh
the famous scene with uh uncle um
yeah you know what i'm talking about
like oh my gosh that was not acting and
he's like crying like dude i just got
the chills this dude ain't enacting his
dad look he's personally experiencing
this right
will is a guy
that many men in america relate to i
just think he um
i think hollywood life is a very
different kind of a life to try to make
marriage personal life conservative all
this stuff work it's so confusing to be
in it you have to play certain card to
get certain jobs to stay relevant to get
the 20 million dollar per film you have
to listen to your publicists you can't
use this word be careful with this
audience those guys said this to you now
you're doing social media now you're
making your own youtube try not to touch
this it's such a big mess that he's
going he's trying to keep his marriage
together but if i can give advice if i
if i'm if i'm in that situation do you
know what i think is the best thing for
them to do all right to get a divorce i
think that's the best you actually think
that's what i think that's the right
thing they should do i think they should
get a divorce and move on i mean if
they're already if they're already
sleeping around with other people you
practically have a divorce at this point
i mean that doesn't make a good marriage
whatsoever well let's say they've been
doing it for 25 years dude right right
yeah i mean you should in my opinion you
shouldn't be getting together with
someone in the first place for
appearances or whatever i mean yeah as
marriage you know to me as a christian
as a holy thing getting together with
someone like that and then having
affairs all the time with all sorts of
other people i mean especially what you
were just talking about with i think
there's a difference between men versus
women that if a man goes and sleeps
around with other women it isn't looked
at as bad but a woman who does it
despite her man yeah makes the man look
a lot worse just because of the
differences between the two so that's
why people would call will smith simp
yeah but but i don't i don't know if he
okay a lot of people call him a simp
it's easy to call him that right now i
mean you had roll you know who i don't
know you're fresh and fit yeah yeah he's
a symphony he's this like they may be
right i don't know if they're right or
not but
you know like everybody was trying to
say who tiger was okay and what tiger
did oh 16 this and you know he went
through this and i don't i don't by his
apologies not sincere enough first of
all before you judge tiger why don't you
go become the best golfer in the world
okay
i mean i read this book the bible that
said what he says before you throw
stones you know
kind of check yourself out a little bit
and i subscribe to that i've never liked
people who judge i grew up in an
environment that was very judgmental i
try to say listen to each a zone i've
been married 12 and a half years i take
it one year at a time love my wife we
got a good marriage we got four healthy
kids we've had a great life some people
want to live a different lifestyle i get
it but i don't think the whole world
knows the whole story i think everybody
is speculating and in reality i think
chris did win
uh i think will is looking extremely
weak and i think will's got to make a
move you know how they used to say to
jlo hey uh your your q score was higher
when you were with ben affleck okay
because you know in the hollywood
marriages it's it it pays to be married
to the right person like you better
believe kanye and
uh uh what do you call it uh yeah that
was through like e-news yeah i mean the
deal that's like a good hollywood
marriage you're married to beyonce i'm
not sure
yeah connie and kim but i'm not joking
yeah that's so i think yeah i don't know
i think if they get a divorce like
listen guys like bezos the husband and
wife the way they got a divorce was very
clear we love each other we've been
together for 25 years
this just didn't work out we still love
our family we still love our kids we
have our own reasons but we have decided
to go a different way we still respect
each other and everybody is like and
they tweeted it same second i don't know
if you remember this it came out same
time you're like yeah
everybody moved on okay it was kind of
like move on i think they got to do
something like that well let me let me
tell you a red table whatever it is and
say red table top announcement to make
we love each other we love our kids
here's what we're doing let me tell you
why you're absolutely right and one
thing that i think you're wrong about i
think you're absolutely right
that will's been doing this thing for 20
something years are you freaking kidding
me
if he wasn't playing around doing things
like this you think he's going to accept
if he's been faithful for 25 years and
his wife has this entanglement she used
that word she was having a full-on
relationship with this guy
and he's embarrassed by this
if you think he was just being acquired
by this whole time and he's allowing
this to happen you're out of your mind
so i 100 agree with you
that he's been doing his own thing on
the side whatever like
he's a g bad boys for life type of thing
where i think you're wrong
is the divorce thing i think if they
were gonna get a divorce it would have
been two years ago at this point
i think like they've been through hell
and back
and this whatever is happening right now
is just making their bond stronger
because the world is against you're
saying i'm wrong it won't happen or
you're saying i'm saying i don't think
the right move i i just don't think
all that i don't think it's happening i
don't think they will do it you don't
think i would have divorced here years
ago but wait a minute you don't think
it's the right move today for both of
them mutually to agree to move on i
don't okay and why is that
i just think at this point they're
fixed in together now if if i were will
i would have divorced years ago and now
it's like two screwed up people who are
just exactly what they do it's like two
alcoholics they're just gonna stay
together
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]